President Joe Biden is threatening  higher taxes on oil companies if they  don't work to lower gas prices he says  he will pursue specifically targeting  oil companies with higher taxes if they  don't actively and in good faith work to  lower gas prices their profits are a  windfall of War I think that this is  fine but the most important issue with  the entire discussion on gas prices is  we should be getting away from gas  powered vehicles we should be getting  away from gas powered vehicles there is  an argument to be made that higher gas  prices actually help achieve that more  quickly the more expensive it is to keep  driving a gas-powered vehicle the more  attractive by comparison an electric  vehicle is however in the short run this  is high gas prices affect many people  Joe Biden should do what he can on the  issue although I don't think he can do  that much but long term we've got to get  off these gas burning Vehicles give me a  break enough is enough